[Musique]
au pied des remparts de semur en auxois
une petite porte s'ouvre sur un jardin
secret des allées des terrasses des
aménagements paysagers dessinée au
xviiie siècle ressortent de l'oubli des
bénévoles regroupés au sein d'une
association ont décidé de redonner vie
au parc jolie longtemps laissé à
l'abandon
il était devenu une véritable jungle
quand on a récupéré le parent qui avait
l'oreille de trois mètres de ronces et
on peut quasiment pas entrer donc c'est
à la machette au sécateur ce mur là on
pouvait pas passer quasiment dans
l'allée donc je me suis dit je vais
démarrer j'étais un peu inquiet j'ai
demandé à grain le chantier d'insertion
de venir me dégager tout la terre et les
blocs et moi je suis reparti un peu
comme un chirurgien de 2,0 l objet posé
mes premiers blocs j'ai trois semaines
après hier il était fini voilà mais les
endroits qu'on refera pas parce que
c'est c'est cyclopéen restauration de
murs débroussaillage bûcheronnage
élagage des travaux supervisés par un
architecte paysagiste car le parc situé
en secteur sauvegardé et classé monument
historique et a2 déclaré demi donc là
par exemple ya un promontoire qui monte
sur une autre terrasse et après une
petite vallée sauvage avec des pièces
d'eau un bois d'un hectare qu'une grande
allée cavalière
voilà donc c'est vraiment un pacte pour
ça que bon on dit jardin mais c'est le
parc jolie avec tous et tous ces
atmosphères différentes
un peu dangereux
voilà on arrive du promontoire qui est
en fait charmant qui domine la
l'armançon et puis une vue vraiment
vraiment jolie sur les tours de ce mur
ces deux grands arbres qui ont
probablement 200 250 ans at il est un
marronnier respectable c'est en 1815 que
la famille joly des notables semurois
premier propriétaire du parc ont
commencé par acquérir un jardin des sens
dans près de la rivière
il avait donc cette propriété qui allait
sur la rive droite de l'armançon et en
1820 ils ont acheté peu à peu des
parcelles sur la rive gauche et ils ont
de proche en proche réunit un parc de
huit hectares un plan original dès 1872
montre l'étendue du parc sillonné
d'aller avec des jardins à la française
un potager un verger dont il ne reste
plus grand chose aujourd'hui
depuis le haut du domaine une source
alimente un réseau hydraulique ajouté au
début du 20e siècle qui recèle encore
bien des secrets
là on va retrouver une canalisation qui
part des flics du déversoir qui répare à
bord l'association a signé un bail d'une
durée de 30 ans pour financer la
restauration elle espère un grand nombre
d'adhésions des dons le soutien de la
fondation du patrimoine
pourquoi pas décrocher le label jardin
remarquable elle veut bien sûr ouvrir le
parcours public
je pense que les gens sont va être
content de retrouver un espace où ils
vont pouvoir se balader avec des points
de vue qui ne ne connaissent pas ce que
ce jardin et vient d'être resterait donc
personne dans la ville n'en soupçonnait
l'existence
j'habite à semur depuis longtemps je
passe très souvent
sur le pont d'un côté de l'autre
derrière mais je soupçonnais pas du tout
c'est tellement ce parc qui commence à
avoir des allures de parc
premier rendez vous prévus dès l'été
prochain avec un concert de jazz le 22
juin